[Applaudissements]
8 la crise économique ce pool amérique
les bourses s'effondrent
la récession a des répercussions
mondiales victime de l'avidité des
banques et de wall street
des millions d'américains se retrouve
sans le sou obligés de vendre leur
maison à rabais et de se tourner vers
les banques alimentaires les
investisseurs se méfient des grandes
bourses
ils sont nombreux à se tourner vers un
marché de petites actions à faible
valeur villepinistes à sarsan d'un
casino les gens vont là pour prendre un
risque et la méconnaissance ou
l'incompétence l'appât du gain fait en
sorte qu'elle communauté qui leur
engagement une nouvelle génération de
promoteurs boursiers jeunes branchés sur
les réseaux sociaux voient le jour sur
le web
making money internet regorge des offres
plus alléchantes les unes que les autres
[Applaudissements]
deux jeunes loups de montréal vont
profiter de la vague pour faire des
millions avant de disparaître dans la
nature
mais avant ils auront croisé le fer avec
d'autres personnages dans le domaine le
vieux routier
les enquêteurs de la haye m et un fils
de promoteurs qui voulait faire partie
de la meuse
[Applaudissements]
c'est un auteur qui est ici depuis
depuis juin 2010 il a bougé depuis juin
2010 c'est la dernière fois que vous
l'avez conduite
ouais danois y en a connu des jours plus
heureux
on est coincé coincé contre le mur
ça fait 75 morts de gens 75 - sans
assurance pour l'auto sans assurance
pour la maison sans assurance vie pas
d'assurance pour le faire prier en 2010
l'autorité des marchés financiers a fait
bloquer par les tribunaux ces comptes de
banque une somme de 3 millions $
aujourd'hui danois yens et son épouse
carole font face à des accusations
d'avoir manipulé le marché mais ils se
défendent bec et ongles d'avoir enfreint
les règles ryan a commencé comme
courtier un jour il décide de partir à
son compte
désormais il s'occupe de propager sur
internet les bonnes nouvelles au sujet
des entreprises afin d'attirer les
investisseurs
en 2004 le couple fondent dans giallo
capitaux une firme de consultants
consultations avec des petites
compagnies qui cherche avoir plus de
visibilité dans fire se spécialise dans
la promotion de 'penny stock' des
actions qui s'échangent souvent à moins
d'un dollar il s'agit d'un marché hors
bourse
parfois appelé pink sheet on y retrouve
des petites entreprises dont les titres
se vente de gré à gré les penny stock et
en a beaucoup mais beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup quand ces compagnies avaient
besoin de visibilité et approche des
personnes que nous avons
mais le marché des penny stocks et
hautement spéculatif contrairement aux
bourses traditionnelles comme celle de
new york de toronto ce marché n'exige
pas de rapports financiers ou de
prospectus et donc les investisseurs s'y
aventurent à ses risques et périls
c'est un marché qui est plus dangereux
dans le sens où il n'est pas beaucoup
encadré ou peu dans là dedans donc on a
les gens de tout acabit de tout des
profils tout ça et comme on dit souvent
le penny stock ça ressemble un petit peu
de façon péjorative un casino le fait
d'être moins surveillées rend les penny
stock plus propice aux stratagèmes
frauduleux
l'idée c'est de faire croire que le
titre vaut plus que ce qu'il vaut
réellement donc on crée une fausse
demande donc avec plusieurs individu ou
un groupe d'individus où on va faire
monter la cote on va beaucoup en acheter
ce qui fait que la cote monte
s'il ya beaucoup de demandes par rapport
à une offre on le fait monter on va le
faire monter assez pour que les gens
suivent par effet d'entraînement ce qui
est en train de monter c'est le temps
d'acheter la seule façon de faire du
bien ça titres qui valent rien il faut
vraiment le faire gonfler beaucoup un
peu de levure comment format qui gonfle
vraiment pourquoi ensuite quand on
tourne mais au fond et va tomber c'est
ce qu'on appelle le pont benton en tant
que fermier mais l'offre au public ont
fixé la valeur initiale départ puis on
les rondes et rapidement à des proches
dans le film le loup de wall street
le courtier john beyrle frites recrute
des promoteurs pour convaincre les
investisseurs d'acheter les actions
faisant ainsi gonfler la valeur
le but est de tout liquider une fois la
cote multipliés et les gagnants sont
ceux qui ont prévu mais la vraie
question est la suivante
cette pratique était légale ce pas
interdit de dire que mon stock et le
plus beau c'est magnifique j'ai une idée
géniale c'est l'idée du siècle j'ai
trouvé le meilleur médicament au monde
la meilleure application la meilleure
voiture et ainsi de suite la tendance à
l'exagération dans ce marché est
extraordinaire parce que un stock qui
coûte 5 en dessous
qu'est ce qui va vous dire voilà qu'il
ait reconquis la vente une énormité vous
faire croire qu'un jour il va valoir 200
dollars donc c'est pas interdit
d'embellir le problème c'est qu'on n'a
pas le droit d'en b lire au point de
manipuler un investisseur grâce au web
le bassin de joueurs en bourse explosent
des activités autrefois réservé aux
professionnels sont même pas accessible
à tous en un clic
c'était révolutionnaire
dès le début on a vu les promoteurs de
penny stock adopté internet presque
instantanément
myriam cela a révolutionné cet été chef
du renseignement auprès de l' asc la
security and exchange commission
l'équivalent de la mf aux états unis il
sort soudain on a vu l'apparition d'un
grand nombre de forums de discussion et
de pourriels qui vantait les mérites des
titres parfois il savait que c'était le
jeu qu'on gonfle et la valeur de
l'action qu'il fallait investir tous et
revendre avant et ça ne s'effondre les
gens plus jeunes qui aiment la bourse y
en a beaucoup
c'est sur l'un de ses sites investor zab
que dan fait la rencontre d'un jeune
étudiant en finances eric 28 yens dany
si impressionné qu'il embauche comme
employé les mêmes beaucoup de marcheurs
ils vivaient là marché puis adoré le
marché cette grâce aux étoiles était
toujours le premier au bureau le dernier
à partir travailler le soir
travailler la fin de semaine avait tout
en irrigué dans la jeune vingtaine
il est ambitieux il cherche à poux fini
le modèle d'affaires de danse ailleurs
il propose de lancer un site internet un
site consacré à la promotion de penny
stock explosif taxe point com prend son
envol y avait toujours des idées des
fois c'est à l'envers
mais boucher deux heures sous les débris
de verre de la personne qui fait grand
beau chargé facile face à un des
premiers coups de marketing est une
réussite
le nombre d'abonnés au site grimpe en
flèche on a fait notre site décembre
2009 quand le monde le fondeur pour ce
le boss planteurs et notamment terre
promise et waouh ça marche bien
l'isaf était très grosse tout à coup on
nous hue au niveau technologique
malheureusement le 7e marché beaucoup
mais y enfoncent entendeur pourquoi
malheureusement pas ce que c'est on est
assis aussi aujourd'hui à cause de ces
journées là où j'aurais pu dire je ne
veux pas faire
dan et eric reçoivent une commission
sous la forme d'actions dont ils font la
promotion
c'est ainsi que leurs comptes de banques
se mettent à grossir
eric l'ex étudiant es employé dans un
restaurant sur la rive-sud deviez
millionnaire c'est donc ça commence à
changer mais pour eric ça change
rapidement
c'est aller à sa taille tout ça c'est en
avesnois si je puisse marquettois je
suis plus jeune j'ai pas envie de
confier à faire que de rester un peu
surpris j'ai appelé ma femme j'ai des
salariés s'en va avec tout est déjà puni
seuls 28 yens prend le contrôle du site
et le couple décide de le poursuivre en
justice
mais c'était sans compter l'arrivée de
nouveaux personnages dans le décor ou
plutôt à la porte
il frappe chez vous laisse tomber la
relance
eric van hulle yen est poursuivie car
danois jan et cajon le clown qui veulent
récupérer leur site promotionnel mais
l'arrivée d'un habitué des penny stocks
vient contrecarrer leurs plans pour les
papas chaudat à ma porte et tu dis
peut-être une bonne idée que tu donnes
ne s'est éteinte à poursuites légales
quand éric parce que moi je vais
redevenir partenaires avec lé fidjien va
avec et puis on va se bat pas 106 nous
ont ils vont gérer explosif store j'ai
dit enfin que ces promotions sont
troublants avec des gens comme ça
tony papa est un homme d'affaires
propriétaire de salons de coiffure
il a déjà eu une entreprise de
recouvrement mais ce sont ses liens avec
certains membres influents de la mafia
qui ont attiré l'attention l'écouté
électronique de la grc pendant
l'opération colisée avec à petit une
conversation au café consenza où
certains lieutenants parler de lui ce
quand même pas banal d'être associés aux
gens de la mafia mais le mot soucier
c'est un gréement je suis pas associé
avec la mafia
vito thème très fermé de moi je
comprends pas que ça me demande d'être
des problèmes c'est quoi la question que
je me demande c'est quand même un peu
bizarre que vous soyez un très bon ami
de vito rizutto dit quand même le top de
la mafia à montréal je fais pas partie
de ces affaires ce que je comprenais
j'ai pas de commerce avec vito rizzuto
des amis personnels
c'est des amis personnels on a vu les
amis mais ça finit là
dan et carole affirme qu'il est venu les
menaces et à deux reprises ce qu'il nie
j'ai jamais menacé personne spécialement
daniel et moi je fais appel je fais des
ménages
en tout pas du tout c'était dans la
terre
l'accord par hanoï a tout inventé ça
complètement complètement
quoi qu'il en soit d'année carole décide
d'abandonner la poursuite et il sait
explosive stocks avant nuit yen qui
voulaient partir en affaires avec tony
pas pas à l'école parce que je préfère
ne pas avoir l'argent et ne pas avoir un
problème et ne pourra rester dans
l'intérieur d'une auto et nagoya
il a fini de travailler avec daniel ryan
parent isolé avec moi qu'on s'est
rencontrés on a fait une nouvelle
compagnie après 12 jours on a fermé les
portes que je voulais pas faire
pourquoi je voulais pas faire la même
chose que dans l'imaginaire à leur fiche
de tout ça veut dire de leader on
attendait pas on n'est jamais fait
affaire même pas fait d'amis carole font
une croix sur cette aventure et lance un
nouveau site promotionnel penny stock
chez soeur points comme gimme more
le succès du site dépassent leurs
attentes ils vendent des titres qui ont
pris de la valeur grâce à leur promotion
des milliers des millions en 14 mois
même votre chine trouve que c'est
beaucoup
mais ça ne devait pas durer en voulant
régler l'addition au restaurant un matin
de juin 2010 ils s'aperçoivent que leur
carte de guichet ne fonctionne plus la
mef enquêtait sur leurs activités avec
la sci aux états unis et avait fait
bloquer leurs comptes qui nous arrêter
dans ma petite copine dans la définition
de camping ainsi que tu fais dans zone
interdite et tu contrôles les nouvelles
ont créé par les nouvelles que tu
contrôles
le montant de ce type honnête
penny stock chez sur détenait peut-être
encore un c'est terminé pour dan ryan et
carol mckeown
mais eric 28 yens lui ne ralentit pas
ses activités sur le web les sites
promotionnels se multiplient il va
s'associer à l'autre jeune loup john
barry can qui se livraient lui aussi à
la promotion de penny stock en ligne il
collectionnait les voitures de luxe dont
une bugatti qui vaut 2 millions de
dollars
le jet privé les maisons à los angele à
nassau il ne se privait de rien il
s'était acheté ce modeste cottage à
laval mais planifié passé à plus grand
encore une maison de
mille pieds carrés qu'il voulait à
l'image de celle de tony stark dans le
film iron man ça va commencer ici jusque
là avec l'entrée de garage ici est
vraiment comme un petit gars qui veut
laver l'argent pour faire pour réaliser
ses rêves
les excès de john dalli piano lui ont
valu l'attention du fils en 2012
revenu québec va chercher à récupérer 6
millions de dollars en cotisations
c'était avant que l' agence du revenu du
canada ne réclame de son côté plus de 15
millions de dollars
mais john babikian n'était déjà plus au
pays
il avait élu domicile à monaco en 2014
la sc dépose des accusations contre
nouveau groupe de promoteurs boursiers
pour une fraude de type phantom de plus
de 200 millions de dollars
parmi eux eric van nguyen et john caby
kahn le fait de réussir à faire
augmenter la valeur de 5 titres à 200
millions $ est exceptionnel
c'était presque du jamais vu durant la
période où je travaille
trois ans auparavant la mf avait ouvert
une enquête sur les activités boursières
de baby cannes il ne s'est jamais
présenté à une convocation pour un
interrogatoire et ses comptes de banque
se trouve à l'étranger
eric van nguyen lui est passé par les
bureaux de l'autorité des marchés en
on l'a interrogé dans le cadre de l'
enquête qui visait d'année car up
nous avons obtenu la transcription de
l'interrogatoire et même si on le
soupçonne de manipulation boursière
28 yens n'a fait l'objet d'aucune mesure
en 2016
la révélation des panamas peppers est
allé au grand jour les noms des
actionnaires de plus de 200 mille
sociétés offshore dont eric 28 yens
nos collègues de la cible ici ont
contacté le chef des enquêtes de l'amf
qui étaient en place à l'époque
aujourd'hui il est en pratique privée
puisque le reportage porte sur
l'organisme et sauve en huitièmes il a
refusé de donner une entrevue à la
caméra nous avons approché la mf pour
comprendre comment s'étaient déroulées
les enquêtes mais comme le dossier de
tanner car lors des devant les tribunaux
on a préféré ne pas commenter
quant à 28 yens il serait toujours au
canada mais nous nombreuses tentatives
pour le joindre sont restées vaines
[Musique]
quelle est la capacité d'un régulateur
comme la mf d'accrocher toutes les penny
stock tout ce qui se passe sur un marché
on peut espérer qu'ils puissent couvrir
tous les produits mais on sait que
matériellement
ils ne peuvent pas vu là elle comme on
dit la venue de l'espace numérique de la
société ita aussi qu'ils ne peuvent pas
car j'ai la chance de trouver un cas ou
situations ou qui sont facilement rendez
entre guillemets attrape abl donc je le
fais immédiatement versus si je vais
attraper quelqu'un qui est des comptes
de banques offshore 6 et sabyc transju
états unis à londres et à singapour peu
plus difficile comment vous expliquez
que on vous arrête vous qu'on vous
accuse vous mais pas les autres je pense
que c'est motivé par le fait que tout le
monde a pris leur actif ils ont mis en
chauffe et la mecque ne peut pas saisir
d'argent qui ont pas accès car europe et
moi on est 100% convaincu
on n'est pas des gens qui ont dit qu'on
est on ne peut pas faire des choses
qu'on connaît puis éventuellement et 10
en anglais de trust marre
mais ça ce sera à la cour d'en décider
et leur procès n'aura lieu qu'en février
[Musique]